[Music]
they're not just collateral damage
journalists are targets in the
information war over ukraine
when the photo ops just not worth it
british royals get a cool reception in
the caribbean
and piling up the likes defectors from
north korea are vlogging down south
hello i'm richard gisbert and you're at
the listening post where we don't cover
the news we cover the way the news is
covered for more than three weeks now
medieval in southeastern ukraine has
been under siege and constant
bombardment survivors are describing our
ruined hellscape of a city with bodies
piling up in the streets
russia has used these tactics before in
aleppo syria blockading the city cutting
the flow of information creating panic
and confusion trying to break the will
of the people the russians are
encountering a form of resistance that
is digitally armed journalists and
citizens equipped with mobile phones are
providing the reporting and that's put
them in the kremlin's crosshairs
president vladimir zelinski is also
getting his side of the story out the
former actor is rallying and uniting
ukrainians and delivering some carefully
crafted speeches to foreign audiences
russia has expertise in the art of
information warfare but this time it's
not going as planned our starting point
this week is mario paul
[Music]
this is what remains of mario paul in
southeastern ukraine
a besieged city the kremlin does not
want the world to see
a maternity hospital bombed
graves piling up
images captured by two ap journalists
who say their names were on a list to be
hunted down by russians as they reported
with no information coming out no
pictures of demolished buildings and
dying children russian forces could do
whatever they wanted
if not for us
there would be nothing
and while those soldiers are out to stop
journalism they may as well target any
ukrainian with a mobile phone
[Music]
ukrainians have been
incredibly effective communicators
because they've got a good story to tell
but they're doing what anyone in this
situation in the 21st century would do
instead of taking selfies of yourself
like in a shopping mall you are taking
selfies of yourself in a bomb shelter
and you're pushing the mouse and to you
know you're contributing to telling the
stories
smartphones have become like a weapon in
this war
but every coin has two sides and
every
video that shows the debris of russian
rockets that can be geo-located
helps russian military intelligence to
understand
uh where they hit and correct their fire
like next time
and the recent example was a tick tock
video posted by ukrainian tick talkers
that showed ukrainian tanks just moving
around this
shopping mall
and russians saw that video
and they bumped
the mole killing eight people
this is a delicate line you know um what
you actually report on uh don't report
on your own troop movements because that
will highlight them to the enemy who
will strike at them
but on the other hand you know people uh
want to record they want to document
they were the future uh whether it's for
the outside world or for their children
history is being written as as we talk
and these days are not going to be
forgotten
where russian forces have been unable to
take control of an area such as
ukraine's second largest city harkief
they have forced the population into
submission through air strikes and
artillery harkiev has been leveled
largely abandoned and maria avedieva has
stayed behind she's new to citizen
journalism a would-be witness to war
crimes who does her work with one eye on
the international court of justice in
the hague
i am here to document the war crimes
committed by putin and his regime i was
not
no a war reporter or
anyone who was active on social media
but when the war started and i saw that
the this information where you coming
out of russia i saw that my role in this
fight might be in information
battlefield they deny the fact of war in
ukraine they deny the effect of genocide
killing of civilians and children
because russia uses information as
another kind of weapon you hear this
challenge right now when i speak to you
that it doesn't stop day and night
russia continues terrorizing my seat so
that's why i'm trying to give as much
information from the ground so then the
uh court in haiti will use this
evidences to punish those who were
responsible for committing war crimes in
ukraine
[Music]
having sent so many compelling
dispatches from kiev attracting the
attention of international audiences
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
now knows he has to keep it
the former actor who played a fictional
president in a television series before
being elected to the real job has
brought some of his production team with
him script writers turned speechwriters
they have tailored his speeches for
specific politicians overseas
some churchillian rhetoric for british
parliamentarians
language that's altered for the us
congress
and again for the israeli knesset
tapping into the histories of those
countries as a way of direct messaging
their people and political leaders
zielinski has a very competent group of
speech writers
scenario writers
he came to power
after a tv series than which he played a
crusading reformer
so he already had a team steeped in
the realities of the ukrainian political
situation
remember among the more successful
american presidents in terms of public
performance was ronald reagan uh who was
an actor
zelinski is an actor he knows how to
deliver he knows how to turn on emotions
play on emotions
countries can be compassionate but still
they present their own interests and
they value their own history
america is only about america mostly
that is why zilensky has been trying
like to put
them in our shoes
we have this young charismatic leader
in his military fatigues in the middle
of the action and on the other hand is
puffy
putin
on the side of a very long table too
afraid apparently to meet people face to
face
but having said that putin is coming
across as the leader that he wants to
come across to the russians right now if
you watch russian tv he is confident he
he is saying that you know white is
black and anap is down and he's saying
that russia is defending itself and
russia is liberating and so on but he's
also
incredibly
um sort of confident and father
figure-like
[Music]
with all of the news channels the
kremlin has at its disposal and a
disinformation industry that's been
years in the making
vladimir putin entered this war of
narratives holding most of the cards
despite that the russians have proven
incapable of stopping the news coming
out of the battlefield citizen
journalism powered by mobile phone
technology is a big part of that so is
traditional war zone reporting
correspondence and camera crews in the
field with targets on their back
ukraine in its darkest hour is
experiencing a golden age of journalism
if that's any consolation
they are reporting from the most
difficult conditions not just shelters
villages outside of kiev that are being
warmed from kharagil from marijuana
whatever i salute them these are genuine
heroes of our time unsung heroes you
know their names will probably never be
known to the outside world but they are
really setting a heroic example and they
are
rehabilitating journalism in ukraine
britain's biggest miscalculation in this
war has been
ukrainian resistance and
ukrainian resilience
the way that the ukrainian identity
has been shaped by the revolutions and
by the war of the last decade
has been incredible to watch
seeing an
apathetic post-soviet society
wake up and take charge of itself
ukrainians kind of have put him to thank
for that because he
really brought them together
this is a society that is operating on
adrenaline right now entirely
and we should be really conscious of
that behind that strength and that
resilience is
is an enormous trauma
[Music]
when the british royal family goes out
on tour visiting former colonies or
countries in the commonwealth the idea
is to cement diplomatic relations and
generate some positive headlines that's
not how things have gone down on the
latest royal tour of the caribbean
meenakshi ravi is here with more
the caribbean is one of the last
significant bastions of the british
empire the uk has six dependent
territories there and many independent
countries like antigua and barbuda the
bahamas and jamaica still have the queen
as head of state
however there is a growing movement to
cut ties with the former colonizers and
that's the backdrop against which this
royal tour is taking place
buckingham palace dispatched some of its
most photogenic faces prince william and
his wife catherine to the caribbean but
before they set out 100 prominent
jamaican citizens signed an open letter
saying that they saw quote no reason to
celebrate queen elizabeth's reign
for british media outlets many of which
were sticking with the customary cheery
headlines the unrest in the caribbean
has been befuddling a bbc radio show
touched upon the subject
britain's colonial past should the royal
family say sorry there was hardly any
discussion about the years of slavery
indentured labor and exploitation which
is what so many caribbean people
consider the true legacy of british rule
with protests forcing the royals to
change their tour plans british tabloids
remained resolutely obtuse
this columnist in the daily mail decided
to bash meghan markle the mixed race
wife of prince harry for creating bad
blood between jamaicans and the royals
on tour
this visit has not done anything to
change the course jamaica has declared
for itself
in a departure from the usual smiles and
glad handing for the cameras the prime
minister of jamaica chose his moment
with prince william to make his
country's intentions clear we are moving
on
there are other caribbean countries also
making noises about becoming republics
when their time comes and they choose
their new heads of state it won't be
someone in london wearing a crown
thanks mina
the distance between the capitals of
north and south korea pyongyang and
seoul is just 200 kilometers but those
cities like the two countries and their
societies are worlds apart
north koreans live under an oppressive
totalitarian regime and many south
koreans see them as backwards somehow
inferior stereotypes that get reinforced
in the country's media
there are north koreans on a mission to
change that defector vloggers who
following their escape into south korea
have turned up on a platform they had
never even heard of while growing up
youtube they vlog about everything from
dating to dancing to dictatorship they
say they want to tell real stories about
life up north
the videos are proving popular with
south korean audiences challenging their
perceptions and showing that their
neighbors aren't that different after
all the listening posts johannahus now
from seoul on the north korean youtubers
showing a different side of a country we
know too little about
born and raised in north korea
without computers or mobile phones
they are some of south korea's most
unlikely new internet sensations
defectors turned youtube stars
[Music]
when you say north korea many people
think of politics kim jong-un and
nuclear bombs because that's how the
country is covered in the mainstream
media
i run a youtube channel that portrays
the real life of north koreans
reflecting my experience of living there
for 18 years
what north koreans eat how they sleep
what they enjoy just basic everyday life
my approach is to create fun light
content about north korea for people to
enjoy
i was born in a place called the aog
coal mine a labour camp for political
prisoners who were caught opposing the
north korean regime
aochi is not well known even to people
in north korea
[Music]
and so i wanted to be the first to share
the information about the place to tell
people about what i have been through
and what other families are still going
through over there viewers respect my
honesty people are moved by it that's
why they're drawn to my youtube channel
choi and puck are two of dozens of
defectors who have turned to youtube and
vlogging following their escape from
north korea
some focus on entertainment from dating
to fashion even pornography
others have gone down a more serious
route vlogging about past hardship or
the challenges of assimilating to life
in the modern capitalist
whatever the content the videos have
proven a hit with south korean audiences
south koreans are
curious about north korea but
they do not have any opportunity to
encounter
actual north koreans in their everyday
lives
they're very marginalized
the information provided by mainstream
media are quite limited
so the vivid and personal storytelling
about north korea is very appealing to
south korean audiences
part of the success for the north korean
vloggers and youtubers has been that
they've been able to
portray and share a much more
three-dimensional view of life in north
korea
being able to meet somebody whether it
be in person or online that can flesh
out this image of north korean people
it's not just
a kind of faceless voiceless population
that are suffering up north but they're
individuals and they have their own
interests
choi and puck's growing number of
subscribers reflect their popularity
their videos regularly generate tens of
thousands of views
before the more than 33 000 defectors
currently living here well the reviews
tend to be a lot more negative
stereotypes of north koreans as
backwards inferior even dangerous are
quite common and at times even
reinforced in south korean media
take now on my way to meet you a part
talk show part talent show starring
female defectors
[Applause]
or the [ __ ] club
another so-called defector infotainment
program that has been a favorite on the
south korean airwaves
their producers claim that these shows
foster understanding between the two
koreas but skeptics have called them
reductive doing more to reinforce than
to break down stereotypes
[Music]
mainstream south korean media have
portrayed north koreans as
the distant other
who are struggling from extreme poverty
and
whose lifestyle is a few decades behind
that of south koreans the mainstream
mass media's format and theme
may not necessarily allow the defectors
to speak about what they really want to
say
these shows are produced by thoughtless
south korean producers the focus should
be on people like my father who was a
camp prisoner for 30 years people who
were persecuted
i promised myself that i would never lie
about my identity once i settled in
south korea
but when i was in university one of the
students said to my face
why does our government keep accepting
these communists feeding them with our
tax money they should all be executed
and their heads should be thrown into
the river
that statement was
incredibly hurtful
we came to south korea to be accepted
yet people here also say that north
koreans should all be executed
fortunately now through youtube we can
tell our stories and i'm glad i can make
my voice heard
youtube
south koreans have a tendency to
stereotype people from north korea as
violent as people who speak differently
and who need help because they are not
self-reliant i'm not running my youtube
channel just because of this prejudice
against north koreans but to communicate
who we really are through our stories
it is then up to my audience whether
they change their views or stick to
their old perspectives
despite their popularity vloggers have
faced criticism both from south koreans
but also from within the defector
community
they've been accused of sensationalizing
and trivializing the north korean
experience exploiting their community
stories for clicks likes views and money
for me
running my own youtube channel is not
just about the money it's about
conveying the story based on just the
facts without exaggeration
for example i rely on google earth to
show where the aog camp is located
i tell personal stories
i realized if i'm honest and i'm being
true to myself then even people who are
critical might change their perspective
as they get to know me better yeah
you know what i'll always say with north
korean
stories and information there's actually
no need to exaggerate it it's already
shocking enough north korean defectors
will actually keep each other
accountable one person in the community
is you know sharing misinformation and
or totally sensationalizing their story
and so on they'll be criticized by other
north koreans probably more so even than
south koreans
defector's stories offer a rare insight
into life in one of the most sealed off
countries in the world
but sharing facts about north korea be
it on tv or online can come at a cost
for those who have fled or those they
leave behind
for joy it's a risk she was willing to
take
sometimes i noticed threatening comments
on my channel posted by north korean
agents i just delete those i don't care
i could not run my youtube channel if i
were afraid i believe some south koreans
do not understand how to make the most
of their liberties that's one of the
reasons i keep my youtube channel going
to make people appreciate and enjoy
their freedom
because it is so precious
and finally for more than a month now
ukraine has been all over the news media
outlets are pouring resources into their
coverage and other stories have been
sidelined the kind that during normal
times would be leading newscasts and
lighting up your phone with
notifications so we're closing the
program this week with a reminder of
what you're not seeing in the news as
well as some suggestions of where you
can find reporting that fills the gap
starting with a conflict that's been
under reported for years the war in
yemen the fighting there involving saudi
and emirati forces as well as local
factions has intensified yemen was
already the world's worst humanitarian
crisis two resources to turn to are the
yemen data project it's out to fill the
holes in verifiable information and
nadwa dawsari a conflict analyst at the
middle east institute
there's afghanistan just seven months
ago when u.s led forces pulled out and
the taliban took over it was all over
the news people there are starving
afghan women are facing more and more
discrimination there are all kinds of
stories to tell
[Music]
is worth following online but there are
also many journalists outside
afghanistan reporting on the country
check them out
and ukraine has shunted aside what
should be the world's biggest story the
climate crisis which seldom gets the
coverage it warrants this past week
temperatures in both polls north and
south reached record highs you might
have missed that as well as a warning
from u.n chief antonio guterres said the
world is sleepwalking to climate
catastrophe take a listen to drilled a
true crime podcast about climate change
climate change can be scary but talking
about it doesn't need to be
for those of you on instagram take a
look at earth by helena she summarizes
big climate reports boiling them down
for her followers
we'll be keeping an eye on those stories
and others and we'll see you next time
here at the listening post
[Music]